from an early age were taught to
celebrate winners look up to champions
Revere gold medalists we make fun of
participation trophies I mean when was
the last time you heard somebody
bragging about having a few dozen
followers or a perfectly average salary
so how do you explain the explosion in
popularity in an investment tool that
offers nothing more than a guarantee of
average results nothing fancy just
average strange as it might seem at
first glance the meteoric rise of the
index fund is a lesson in how sometimes
aiming for average might be the best
strategy of all
[Music]
in an earlier episode we explained how
mutual funds offer numerous benefits
like low share prices broad
diversification convenience and ease
their debut in 1924 assured in a golden
age for active portfolio managers
professional investment management was
suddenly no longer just for the ultra
wealthy the American middle-class poured
their savings and retirement accounts
into mutual funds with abandon today
with nearly 10,000 mutual funds
available it can look like a Cheesecake
Factory menu endlessly long and
complicated
so most fund managers compete to deliver
the maximum amount of alpha that's just
investor speak for how much better the
portfolio manager did then the market
average the way managers measure their
success is by comparing their returns to
an index an index is a hypothetical
portfolio that represents a segment of a
financial market for example the S&P 500
index measures the average stock gains
or losses of the 500 largest companies
in the US there are indices for
virtually every type of investment all
across the world precious metals oil
bonds even a pork carcass index their
main use is as a comparison tool for a
long time trying to beat the index with
your mutual fund made sense to most
investors I mean who would want to put
their money with a fund manager who
charged expensive fees but failed to
beat the market most of the time but
then a dirty little secret was uncovered
most professional fund managers
consistently fail to meet or beat their
index by a wide margin one study found
that 90% of active fund managers did
worse than their relative index and
these are supposed to be the best of the
best with Ivy League education
decades of experience and sophisticated
trading tools there are a few factors
that make it difficult for fund managers
to beat the market the first is fees
actively managed mutual funds employ
teams of researchers analysts and
traders that cost money and you the
investor end up paying for it actively
managed funds have annual fees on
average of
1.4% in other words your mutual fund has
to make 1.4 percent per year just to
keep you from losing money a second key
factor is that humans are really really
bad at telling the future in the 1973
book a random walk down Wall Street
Burton Malkiel suggested that investment
markets are too complicated and well
random to be consistently predicted
researchers found that you do just as
well picking stocks blindfolded as you
would giving your money to a portfolio
manager no seriously
in a contest run by the UK observer
professional portfolio managers tested
their skills against the stock picking
prowess of a cat named Orlando Orlando
shredded the pros Malkiel suggested the
creation of a new low-cost mutual fund
that simply buys the hundreds of stocks
within the index and doesn't jump from
stock to stock trying to beat the market
that sounded like a great idea to a guy
named John Bogle in 1975 he launched
vanguards first index investment trust
no more promises beating the market the
only guarantee was that your investments
would do slightly worse than average
since even index funds have minimal fees
sound a little underwhelming yeah it did
to investors at the time too the fund
was ignored or outright mocked for years
and many thought it wouldn't survive
spoiler alert it did over the last half
century more and more investors started
wising up and today index funds and
index ETFs are more popular than ever
with nearly seven trillion dollars
resting and index type funds
it seems the promise of consistently
average results doesn't sound so shabby
to investors anymore this is also thanks
to the investing Godfather Warren
Buffett in 2007 he made a million-dollar
bet with the world's best hedge fund
managers that they couldn't outperform
an S&P 500 index fund over a 10-year
period and wouldn't you know it
despite weathering the Oh 8 crash the
index fund trouts the hedge funds
averaging an annual
7.2% return compared to the hedge funds
measly 2.2 now to be clear index funds
are not the perfect investment there is
no such thing but Warren Buffett
famously quipped that index fund
investing is the best move for 99% of
investors out there so if you decide to
join the club start simple and don't
forget to diversify for example a basic
blend of three broad indices would allow
you to diversify into a huge spread of
countries companies and asset types
index funds are available through most
fun companies and can be bought within a
retirement account like an IRA or 401k
and unless you're a seasoned investor
speaking to a professional to set an
ideal blend is a smart step there are
also online Robo advisor services that
can automatically make a blend for you
based on your goals and risk tolerance
so next time your mama asks if you're
doing your best say actually we're on
Buffett says that I should just strive
to be average she'll be thrilled and
that's our two cents hey guys it's
Phillip and Julia again question how can
you make your favorite meals even more
delicious add a dash of science of
course serving up science is a PBS
Digital Studios show hosted by history
buff a science writer and foodies Cheryl
Kirschenbaum who is serving us science
backed answers to all of our biggest
food questions such as should you let
your meat rest what's better wild or
farmed salmon what makes blue cheese so
stinky yeah I think you mean delicious
so head on over to serving up science
and tell them two cents sent you will be
nerding out right along with you what
else would you like to know about index
funds ask your questions in the comment
section
you
[Music]